NATO and Poland have said that a missile
strike that struck polish territory on
Tuesday was likely fired by Ukraine in
self-defense two people were killed when
the missile exploded in a village near
Poland's border with Ukraine the
incident came on the same day that
Russia bombarded Ukraine with scores of
missiles targeting cities and
infrastructure across the country
mangled Farm Vehicles lie in the huge
crater caused by Tuesday's blast a long
way from the front lines of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
this conflict now arriving at a grain
Factory just three miles across Poland's
border
today investigators combed the wreckage
with poles weary of what's to come
let's wait calmly statistically speaking
it probably had to happen at some point
we are simply so close to Ukraine
I'm waiting to see what happens next how
the state reacts I'm trying not to
succumb to fear I'm waiting for more
information but it's unsettling
the explosion hit as Russia launched a
massive wave of Rocket attacks across
Ukraine but Poland's leaders say they
weren't the target
absolutely no indications that it was a
direct attack on Poland so the fact that
polish territory was hit with a rocket
was not a result of intentional actions
Poland was not a target for the rocket
so in fact Poland was not attacked
NATO has also been quick to de-escalate
the situation cautious that an attack on
one of its members would signal a major
shift in Russia's War our preliminary
analysis
should just start the incident was
likely caused by the Ukrainian air
defense missile
fired to defend Ukrainian territory
against Russian cruise missile attacks
but let me be clear
this is not Ukraine's fault
Russia Bears ultimate responsibility as
it continues its illegal war against
Ukraine
an unfortunate accident this time but a
real threat as the conflict continues on
Poland's doorstep
we've got team coverage of this story
tonight our reporter shigors zimanovski
is in the Polish Village where that
Missile hit yesterday and DW's Terry
Schultz she joins us from Brussels the
city where the headquarters of NATO is
located
it's good to see both of you Jay course
let me start with you you are on the
ground in the village where that missile
exploded what have people told you about
the past 24 hours I mean they could have
been Ground Zero of a much larger War
yes Brent indeed we are in the village
of chevodov where the explosion this
accident yesterday happened you can see
behind me the police have cordoned off
the area
um just a few hundred meters behind me
there is this uh grain drying facility
where the uh where the missiles struck
and the two people have died the people
we spoke to here they told us they are
um they are afraid and the last 24 hours
have been have put them under tremendous
pressure and they told us they could
hear
explosions from
um exposures even further out in the
area they heard two explosions the
people here many thought that it was
maybe a gas explosion or some sort of an
accident but then the news started
trickling in and the reality turned out
more grim and and depressing you know
they know where they live we are right
on the border with Ukraine and it's just
six kilometers away to the border from
here from where I'm standing and you
know they they are they would be they
could be the first one the first ones
who who would be affected in a in a in a
in a case of a bigger
um conflict and they've experienced this
already uh right from the beginning of
the Russian uh full-scale Invasion on
the 24th of February they have been the
first ones to receive Ukrainian refugees
in fact one of the men that were killed
yesterday he was well known here in the
community for going to the Border uh
frequently helping out the refugees so
you know
they've been experiencing this conflict
intensively but the last 24 hours was
obviously another level yeah and in
Terry what about at NATO headquarters I
I'm assuming that the relief must have
been I'm tremendous there that the
alliance is not facing a war with Russia
Today
certainly that is not exactly how
leaders express it but it's obvious
because as was mentioned earlier Not
only would that signal a major shift in
Russia's plans for waging its war on
Ukraine but that would mean that the
response that NATO would have to come up
with would be massively different than
if this was simply an accident and in
fact we know that Poland was Was
preparing to ask for what's called
Article 4 consultations and that means
bringing all the Allies together in in
the case of a security or political
threat to a country and they decided at
the last minute to call that off and so
that was a sign of relief and the other
sign was that NATO Secretary General Yen
stolzenberg went so far as to say Not
only was this most likely not an attack
from Russia of course pending final
investigation but we have no sign that
Russia is planning any offensive attack
on a NATO country so you could
definitely tell that NATO wanted to
de-escalate the fears and she goes
Poland we know has been very vocal in
its support of Ukraine and some people
have said today that
um it's amazing that this type of
accident that we saw yesterday it's
amazing that it hasn't happened earlier
uh have you been hearing that sentiment
yes um
um
you know
people here know uh that there is a
major conflict going right on this side
on the other side of the Border but
still I think few of them have could
have expected that a conflict would
spill into polish territory
we now today hope that you know that the
the nature of this conflict will not
change that I'm I mean that that Poland
or NATO will not be involved at this
point but
um
and you know the the message from the
Polish government is that it is actually
the ultimate that it is Russia that
bears the ultimate responsibility for
this for this tragic incident where as
the Prime Minister uh has called it uh
he uh said that uh that everything
points to the uh points to the scenario
that Ukraine was simply trying to
intercept the Russian rocket we remember
yesterday there was a uh the big
full-scale Russian rocket attack all
across Ukraine so he said so the Polish
prime minister said that
um Ukraine had the right to defend
itself and uh as you said Poland has
been very vocal about his support for
Ukraine and I don't think that this
accident will change anything about that
and Terry Eastern European NATO members
they were they were quick to point
fingers last night you and I talked
about this even before there was any
evidence or any Clarity in the situation
um how did that play out inside
NATO do we know
I don't think that anyone is going to
blame the Eastern European countries for
thinking it was Russia we've all been
worried that this this kind of situation
would happen that there would be a
purposeful attack so I I think that the
relief flooding in that this was simply
an accident uh overshadowed uh any sort
of um blaming for for having come to too
quick of conclusions and as we've been
saying NATO joined the Polish government
in saying that regardless of the fact
that Russia didn't fire this missile it
is because Russia is reigning missiles
down on Ukraine constantly that the
situation even happened so Moscow
certainly wasn't exonerated just because
it didn't fire this missile and briefly
uh before we run out of time Ukraine's
president zielinski he has said that he
believes that the missile was fired by
Russia and not by his own forces is that
causing any type of dissonance um at
NATO I mean he's insisting that he'd be
part of an investigation
yeah I saw that those claims were
continuing even after the NATO press
conference where the the Secretary
General made clear that this is
definitely what everyone believes so I
mean I think it remains to be seen how
that will play out and and if the
ukrainians can bring any sort of proof
that they did this was not one of their
air defense missiles uh but at NATO
headquarters they weren't giving any
Credence to that side of the story yet
even as they said these are just
preliminary findings and we have to wait
for the final final results
uw's Jerry Schultz reporting tonight
from Brussels and
menowski on the ground there in Poland
near the border with Ukraine to both of
you thank you